danny trejo is one of hollywood's most
recognizable bad guys
playing roles in movies and tv like
machete
breaking bad from dusk till dawn and
desperado
but don't let his mastery of tough and
deadly roles fool you
they are nothing like the man himself
now he's looking back in his new memoir
trejo my life of crime redemption and
hollywood
we visited the 77 year old at his los
angeles home to talk about his journey
from the infamous san quentin state
prison
to a life helping others find sobriety
with blockbusters
all along the way
if looks could kill danny trejo just
might be the most
menacing actor in hollywood
channeling his real life rage he created
the ultimate
badass on screen
director loved me the way i was
portraying these guys
and then he said danny how do you do
that i watch you
this killer and then you immediately go
play with your kids
because i've been that guy that guy
makes me sick
being that guy is at the heart of his
cathartic confessional
born in 1944 to mexican immigrants danny
grew up in an abusive home in los
angeles
i can't remember my dad threatening to
kill me you know
seven years old i remember my
grandfather i'll break every bone in
your body
that's when i learned to love my uncle
gilbert my grandfather would be like
this
this tyrant frothing at the mouth at us
i'd be scared to death and killer would
be going
nodding you know he was on heroin i
didn't know it
i wanted to be like that he idolized his
uncle who got him high when danny was
just eight
gilbert put a gun in his hands and
taught him how to act tough
they put me in front of a mirror and
these practices like
give me the money give me the money
gilbert gave me a sawed-off shotgun and
the minute you hold the start-off
shotgun you don't have to say anything
that was my first acting lesson at 13 14
years old
a violent young adult trejo spent 11
years
in and out of california's most
notorious prisons
for crimes including selling drugs and
armed robberies
1968 i made a promise
lord if you let me die with dignity i'll
say your name every day
and i'll do whatever i can for my fellow
inmate and i said inmates i never
thought i was getting out of prison
while behind bars he began attending aaa
meetings and when released in 1969
he became a drug counselor
some 15 years later danny stopped by the
set
of runaway train trying to help a
struggling addict stay clean
the director took notice of his cold
sullen stare
when he learned trejo had been a boxing
champ in prison he put him in the ring
with the film star eric roberts
launching a career
that now boasts some 400 on screen
appearances
the county jail the floors are always
waxed because they have
free labor in his garage full of classic
cars
trejo recreated a prison floor like the
ones he was forced to sleep on
i remember where if i screw up i can go
back real quick you know
how often do you come out here and put a
roll of toilet paper behind your head
yeah once a week once a week really
you got to stay grounded murals of his
movies are also a connection to his past
i put michelle there because she's just
absolutely go to hell gorgeous and i put
her
in front of bob's big boy because we
robbed bob's big boy in 1962.
and inside his home just 13 miles from
where he grew up
he showed us his pride and joy you wear
sparkle shoes
of course these are actually
penitentiary boots
why do you keep these
because i never want to wear them again
it's like people ask me a lot of times
well don't you ever get a yen to use
drugs i never want to go back
i remember showering with 50 men
and try not to look i can remember being
shook down
and being stripped down and that's what
drugs mean to me you know so the shame
the shame that shame motivates his
charity work
going to prisons to speak to inmates
about getting clean
everything good that has happened to me
has happened as a direct result
of helping someone else everything
the tough guy who's really a softy
is taking readers on a frightening
journey from trauma to triumph
what do you hope people take away from
reading this redemption
you know i want people to say that it
doesn't matter where you start
matters where you end up you look super
tough right now
he is quite the softy you know one of
his most prized moments in life is that
he got to meet president obama
and what happened in that meeting is
that president obama sees him steps out
of line and says
i know you machete yes and trejo goes
that's the most terrified i was in my
life that someone was yelling at me you
know she showed me
what a life listen i'm embarrassed to
say i never knew his name but once i see
his face i certainly knew exactly
who he was but i did not know that
backstory
no and you know it's funny he's he's
been in 400 films he has credits to 400
films
he's had the most killings on camera of
anyone that's how
much of a bad guy he is in these films
right and he says sometimes it reminds
him that
you know he his life could have gone the
other way my producer robin singer said
to him
it's shocking to me you've survived this
long
and he said yeah it's sometimes shocking
to me too but it's so remarkable that
he's turned out the way that he has
after being in an abusive home
being given drugs being given a
sawed-off shotgun
that he has turned his life around wow
that's that was a great story i loved
when he said it doesn't matter where you
started that's where you end